Hello, and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
I'm your host, David Flanagan,
also known as Rawkode across the Internet.
Today, we are taking a look at Docker
Slim, and we have two great guests joining
us today.
Now I do apologize for it's been a
little bit late today. I had a skill
run that I had to do, and not
only was I picking up my own kids,
I had to pick up the cousins too.
It's been a hectic day, but I'm really
looking forward to sitting down and chilling out
with some cool technology.
So feel free to say hello in the
chat. This is a livestream. We ask questions.
If there's anything that you're wondering, others may
be wondering it too. So type it into
the chat, and we'll do our best to
answer as we go.
Now, guiding us today in our journey of
Docker Slim is two fantastic guests. I am
joined by Martin and Ivan from the Slim
AI team. Hello. How's it going?
Hello there. Very well.
Hi. Doing great.
You know, I've done over a hundred episodes
now and you think I would learn. But
whenever I have more than one guest, I
don't know why, but I just say, hey.
How's it going? And then expect two people
to try and work out how to sequence
themselves. I really I just I need to
do that better. But thank you both for
joining me. Let's start with you, Martin. Can
you say hello and give us that brief
introduction into you, please? Sure. Hello. My name
is Martin Winpress. I lead
developer relations and community at Slim AI.
And
my background is, well, I'm a a longtime
Linux nerd. And prior to joining Slim,
I was a canonical,
engineering director for Ubuntu.
And prior to that, working on large compute
clusters for
black box,
aircraft aviation flight safety analysis for ten years
or so. So my container
background comes from sort of that that world
predominantly.
Awesome. And Ivan?
Yeah. Well, I'm just a long time software
engineer with a passion to infrastructure stuff
and then with a little bit of software
what's this? Like, site reliability experience
as well. And I've been, like, moving from
being a user, like, a long time user
of containers to a finally, a developer of
a container related technology.
So since May, I am
a part of the Slim AI engineering team
while doing all things containers.
Awesome. Thank you very much. And we've had
lots of hellos in the chat, and I
believe one of your colleagues, we did have
a low from BigPod.
And I'm loving the icon, the BGP. So
I am a bit of a networking BGP
nerd, so I appreciate that all the time.
Alright. Well, thank you for introducing yourself and
sharing a bit more about you.
Can we maybe start by just telling our
audience what
is Docker Slim?
Who wants to tackle that?
Shall I start with the origin story? And
then maybe, Ivan, you can get in sort
of the technical nuts and bolts.
So
Docker Slim was created by our CTO,
Kyle Quest, about seven years ago now.
Actually, a Docker sort of hack fest event,
and it it won I think it was
second place at that event. So that was
where it emerged.
And really what Kyle the problem that Kyle
was trying to solve back
then was how do you make containers smaller
without changing your workflow?
So you're already producing your your Docker files.
You're already producing your containers,
and you want them to be smaller, but
you don't necessarily want to move to another
distribution
in order to get the outcome that you're
seeking. So the idea is is that Docker
Slim is a post processing
capability.
So you produce your containers in the normal
way, and then you can produce these optimized
containers as sort of a a follow on,
event and and produce a separate art artifact.
So in that in that sort of early
time,
the purpose of Docker Slim was to take
your original container as an input and then
create
a smaller container
based on the artifacts in that original container
that has everything inside it that can actually
run your app, you know, be it a
service or a web app or even a
command line utility.
So that's sort of the origin story on
why
Docker Slim does what it does in the
way that it does it. But Yvonne can
give you much more insight into sort of,
you know, how it actually works internally
and some of the other capabilities that it's
grown over those seven years.
Yeah. So
the thing is that that, like, I'm myself
being a developer.
I've been struggling with this, like, bloated container
images. Like,
not because of security reasons. Like, security stuff,
it became popular only, like, a few years
ago.
But, like, even five years ago, it was,
like, a constant journey how to make images
smaller.
And for me, it always used to be,
okay. I just need to
be, I don't know, a wizard. I I
I need to understand all these,
like, distros,
which are smaller, which are, like, bigger. Like,
what what packages should I install? What what
should I avoid? And I should not forget
to clean up caches after doing some, like,
you know,
APT get installed and stuff like that. And,
like, it was, like, a craft and and,
like, a hard earned skill.
But then I
just
well, quite recently, I realized that that's not
the only way.
My actual my actual
acquaintance with Slim Eye, it started from slightly
different angle. I I was a long time
fan of the portal of the SaaS portal
we had.
And only later, I learned that there is
a tool behind it, and this tool is
Docker Slim.
And Docker Slim is well,
it's kind of a magical tool.
It's
doing all this image modification for you,
well, automatically.
And the
trick is that
it does a runtime analysis
of your containers.
So instead of now following some
elaborate techniques to build an image,
I could just kind of, go carelessly
go with my favorite Linux distro and
put there are all the packages I need
for my application to run, all the development
packet, all, like, the
source code dependencies I need,
get, like, a one, two gigabyte
big image,
then give it to Docker Slim.
It will run it,
analyze it, and produce a minified version of
this image,
which will be, like, 10 times smaller,
and it will still work.
But, of course, we need to be careful.
Like,
we shouldn't be trusting this tool blindly.
Much like with any other with any addition
to your Dockerfile,
you wouldn't add, you know, like, a line
to drop some caches and then don't check
your final image one more time.
Same with the Docker Slim. Like, once you
minify your image, you still have to be,
like, testing it as as a very final
step.
Yeah. That's how my
kind of Awesome. Journey with Docker Slim started.
Alright. I definitely have questions there. One, because
you said automatic. Whenever I hear automatic, I
have lots of questions that I wanna ask.
But before we get to that, I really
wanna focus on why this is so important.
Right? Like,
if we think back to the earlier container
days,
something I seen, I was a consultant, so
I never actually did any real work back
then, but I was helping people adopt containers.
And what I often seen is they were
taking
these very complex vagrant style builds and just
decking them straight into a container image. Like,
it was not rare to see people
with seven, eight, 30 gig container images back
in 2015,
'20 '16.
I've seen a lot of them. So much
so, I I I wrote an article on
how to debug and make them slimmer using
really crude tools. Nothing as cool as what
we're gonna see today. But literally running
an interactive container, running a command, doing a
Docker dev, seeing what changed, and then tidying
up and then trying to
wrap everything together into these little concrete run
steps. That was painful,
but effective once you got the hang of
it.
Now
what was interesting about what you said there
is you says, I can just build my
image without worrying about that size.
Point Docker Slim to it and it does
some automatic
analysis.
So if we're gonna dig into this in
any of the demos, we can defer it
to LEN, but can we maybe try and
understand what that automatic or what that analysis
looks like? How does it work out, runtime
dependencies?
I'm assuming
there may be some sort of syscalls or
EBPF or something in there. So I'd love
to know more.
Definitely.
I I think I have, like, a tiny
diagram to show, like, the high level idea.
You could open it,
or I can share my screen with that.
No. Is that on the HackMD, or do
you want me to go to the Slim
AI website? What you Yeah. In the doc.
It's the first. It's Slim.
In the HackMD, it's there, but it's also
now GitHub repository,
which is, like, Docker Slim dash Docker Slim
or slash Docker Slim.
Alright. Docker Slim
Docker.
Me make sure I've not got a oh,
I got a four zero four. Github dot
com slash docker slim? Docker dash slim slash
docker dash slim.
The pepcack.
So
Alright. I have it. So I'm gonna share
my screen.
So this is your GitHub repository for the
Docker Slim projects.
Am I gonna say images or the read
me? Just scroll down. Just scroll down a
bit. There we go. Sure. Here we go.
Yeah. So
as I already
said, it's a runtime analysis.
And by runtime analysis, I literally mean running
the target image.
So it's not like we will be
examining
the images content
or the Dockerfile or whatever. No. Instead, we'll
just I mean, Docker stream will just spin
out this container using the so called fat
image. I'm not sure how appropriate is this
language
for our auditory, but
that's what it's called internally.
Like, we take the original fat image, and
we just run it.
And
and Docker Slim, it's like a two
two fold
thingy.
It's a driver app, the one you actually
interact with,
the app called Docker Slim.
And the second part is a Docker Slim
sensor.
It's also a binary,
and it's get injected
into the target container
as a volume.
And then it becomes the
pid one in this
container.
And
it's like the thing
that
is actually doing the
well, we call it monitoring.
But, actually, it's some sort of of a
a tracing.
So it's literally a p trace call,
like, in a loop in a huge loop,
and it takes the used to be entry
point of the container, and it starts profiling
it.
And while doing this, it just keeps all
the system calls that were made,
analyzes them, and extracts
the any path related parameters.
However, this is not the only thing the
sensor does. Sensor actually is pretty sophisticated
piece of software.
It has a lot of
heuristics
and
different,
well, sort of
know hows about
various, like,
execution environments, like Python, for instance.
Because Python, it's a good example. It has
some sort of of a optimization
with this, you know, like, pi
c files that are, like, compiled
Python modules.
And when a new module is imported,
apparently,
only the
this PYC file will be accessed
by the Python in interpreter.
And the sensor actually knows that if it
detects
a
file read
that ends with a PYC extension,
it should go and look up a corresponding
source file.
And it's full of such heuristics for, like,
various languages.
Well, another good example probably is
when a sensor detects a binary file.
And if this file is a binary execution
file or a shared object,
it would just go and check the l
LDD for this file and see all its
dynamic dependencies
to also look them up even
though they might not be accessed during the
execution.
So in the end,
when the underlying
containerized
application is done or we decided to stop
actually
probing it, we will have, like, a huge
list of
all the files
or potential files that are actually needed for
the execution of this application.
And,
yeah, that's how the runtime analysis actually looks.
Okay. Yeah. Now one of the things you
touched on earlier was your nervousness about things
that do things automatically.
And whilst there is some sophistication
and as Yvonne has just described,
a lot of sort of heuristics,
the AI
in our, you know, company name, it is
application intelligence rather than artificial intelligence. It's this
knowledge of different language ecosystems and frameworks that's
that's baked in.
But
you're quite right to suggest that, you know,
purely
automatic
systems
can be prone to error. And one of
the examples we're gonna show when we actually
get into the sort of the hands on
examples later
is how you can feed
the Docker Slim process
additional hints about where it should go and
look and probe the application.
So
I I'm not gonna I'm not gonna talk
about that example specifically,
but sort of one of the best things
that you can do is if you've got
integration tests for your application. So you produce
your container image and you have integration tests.
One of the best things you can do
is when you produce your Slim container with
Docker Slim
is instruct Docker Slim to run those integration
tests
whilst it's observing the application because that should
exercise the application
broadly,
hit all of the different execution paths,
and gather all of that application knowledge in
order to produce
a minimized
optimized container
that actually has everything inside it that the
application requires to run.
Now there are examples where that doesn't work.
For example,
we we did an example recently where we
created the world's best image carousel app because
we were experimenting with different technologies. And we
did that on a livestream, and one of
the things we discovered with that is because,
the images weren't precached in the carousel,
the
container that was produced didn't have all of
the images that should have been inside the
carousel.
So one of the things you can do
is you can tell Docker Slim, actually, I
know I have static assets in this app.
So in this path are my static assets.
You should always include everything in this directory
when you're minifying the container because I know
everything in there you're going it the the
application is going to require whether or not
it got hit during the the the censoring
and observation that that Docker Slim does.
Awesome.
Thank you for all of that context.
I wanna make sure that I understood it,
so I'm gonna try and surmise that all
in, like, two sentences.
But
Docker Slim
will run my container image,
inject in a PID one, which then subsequently
runs the command that my container image is
built to run.
It does Cisco monitoring, which means it's looking
for things like f open for
any file that is opened on that machine.
It keeps track of some
sort of graph or table, and then those
are the files that are propagated down to
the Slim image.
This makes sense. Now I have a question
about that Slim image, but I'll come back
to that in a moment.
You also mentioned you've got some smarts application
intelligence, and I love that use of AI.
Actually, that's that's probably the only valuable use
of AI I've ever heard. Now
and what it's doing
what it's doing is you understand Python. I
mean, that's a it's just a problem for
interpreted languages rather than compiled languages, right, where
they have these different dynamics where they're trying
to speed up that interpreter as much as
possible by doing binary cache in some layer.
So, yeah, you've got knowledge for Python. I'm
assuming maybe Ruby, PHP, other things like that
so that that just works as best as
it can.
You've also told me that I need to
write tests, so I'm I'm obviously guilty of
taking
a little bit lax on the integration test,
but I can understand their You don't need
to, but it will be beneficial.
Because it increases the coverage of the code
path for the Slim AI intelligence,
which I get. Okay.
So I understand the collection.
I understand what it's doing.
I see here on this image, which I
love, is generate security profiles. The fact that
you're doing, I'm assuming, seccomp and Cisco stuff
is you can help build that seccomp profile.
I don't know if that's true, but we
can talk about that later.
My main question right now is about that
image that comes out the other end. Now
are you taking all those files from the
table graph and then putting them into a
scratch image, or are you using a small
base layer that Slim AI has approved with
some tooling or substrate? Like, what what does
that output look like?
It's a scratch.
Like, literally a scratch. And the
well, we will actually see it. If if
you go through this tiny little demo,
the very first one on our list,
we will see exactly how the unified image
looks like.
Yeah. Alright. Well yeah. Go for it. What
you'll what you'll get is a single layer
container image that only contains the assets that
are required to run your application
that came from the original image.
Okay. So, yeah, it's scratch image where you
just throw a lot of stuff at Okay.
Nice. Yep.
I
think we should run through the first demo
then when we move on to the the
hands on component. And then if anyone in
the audience has questions, please feel free to
put them in the chat, and I'll keep
any questions that I have coming as well.
So
I have a nice small machine here for
us to work with today. I
I just love typing h top in this
machine, so I'm gonna do it one more
time. I mean, I can even type.
No. My terminal died.
Uh-oh.
I know what I've done.
Oh, should I help you? Yeah. I've when
I've added your
public key, I've removed my public key.
I'm gonna
I'm gonna sit.
Sit. That
gets repaired,
I I can I can give
an example of a use case of Docker
Slim that we see from our customers to
sort of
fill fill this space whilst you recover your
access? Alright. Well, just quick quickly, Ivan, I
have sent you my public key in the
private chat. Could you add it? Yeah. Thank
you. Alright. Martin, take it away.
So,
one of the use cases that this is
not the exclusive use case. One of the
use cases we see for Docker Slim is
this.
Because you can take literally any image and
make it small and optimized,
and there is we're seeing a trend. So
one of our colleagues,
Aisha, did
a she looked at over a hundred of
the most popular containers at the end of
last year that are published in Docker Hub
and produced a report, a container report, sort
of the the state of the container ecosystem.
And one of the things that we spotted
in that is the proliferation
of
test QA and infrastructure infrastructure
tooling
that makes its way into containers that are
considered production ready that are published in Docker
Hub authoritatively
by the various projects and what have you.
And it's also something we see,
you know, software
houses doing as well.
So one of the uses is this. You
can have large,
well instrumented containers that are
suitable for developers to use for local iterative
development that have all of your tooling baked
in. But then when you want to ship
those containers to production,
you can run them through Docker Slim as
part of your CICD
pipeline
in order to take that sort of dev
environment
and transform it into a production ready container
suitable for deploying in the cloud,
which has the shells and utilities
and infrastructure tooling removed
such that if there is unfortunate bug in
the application that you're writing
and that somebody is able to compromise that
and land inside your container,
they're now inside
a sort of a barren wasteland
where they have no tooling that they can
use against your infrastructure to disrupt your operations
as opposed to landing inside sort of a
richly instrumented container, which has all of the
necessary tooling inside it for them to potentially
island hop and disrupt the rest of your
operations.
So that's one use case we see. Transform
your dev test,
sort of well instrumented containers for iterative development
into production ready containers.
Alright. Awesome.
Okay.
Let's try this again then.
So
finally, I can run htop.
So I spun up a pretty fun machine
on Equinix metal just because I thought it
would be fun. So we have a terabyte
of RAM, which I'm excited to start using
because, you know, sometimes you need a terabyte
of RAM and we have a 28 cores
or threads at least.
The only thing I've done Just a tiny
note. It's not a requirement for the.
No. It def it's definitely not a requirement.
I I I I just wanted to have
some fun.
Usually, use twice bigger machines.
Okay. So what have we done to this
machine in preparation for today's demo? The answer
is not a lot. I have installed Docker.
We have kind available.
We have not spun up any Kubernetes cluster,
and I was also requested to make sure
that we had make and get available.
I believe that was all the prerequisites.
So
pretty much just a basic into install with
a couple of little tools on the top.
Last question then. Ivan, am I allowed to
is
this the HackMD public? Is this something I
can put in the show notes so people
can follow along on their own time?
Yeah. Pretty much, sir. It's nothing secret.
Alright.
And what I will do is I will
just open it here as well so that
people can follow along as we work through
it. So
there's that diagram, and we're gonna work through
demo one basics. So I'm I'm gonna work
through a couple of these ones
to get a feel for it. You just
took and please feel free to add context
and history and all that other good knowledge,
and then Ivan is gonna do something bit
more fun as well for us.
I'll try.
I've got a lot of confidence in you.
Don't worry.
So first thing we need the OC.
First thing we need to do is pull
the CentOS image. So this demo one is
going to make a curl only image from
a full blown CentOS distribution.
So this is that case where you have
this chunky image, but when you go to
prod, you wanna minimize that as much as
possible.
And so we we just want a Slim
image.
Yeah. That was pretty fast, which is good.
So now we're gonna Slim it. And for
that, we need Docker Slim. So I haven't
installed that upfront. I rarely like to do
that upfront. So we're gonna go through the
install process too.
Let me jump back to that GitHub repository.
I'm assuming I just pull a binary from
the releases.
Is there a prepared
I can. Okay. Is there a nicer way?
Can do that. There's also there's also a
simple script which will do all the magic
and grab the latest version. It's all in
the read me and the in the installation
section. I don't read read mes. Come on.
Oh, I know.
How tedious.
Alright.
Installation.
So if you scroll down, there we go.
Scripted install. If you just grab that, that
will that will do what you need. Oh,
there's a homebrew as well for people on
Linux or Mac with brew available. Right?
And a Docker image.
Alright.
I will trust your scripts, which I'm assuming
is curl and pipe into bash. So Don't.
Don't.
Yeah. Yeah. Well, essentially, it's just like two
binaries,
the Docker Slim itself and the Docker Slim
sensor, and a move of these binaries to
the,
well, USR local bin, I guess.
Awesome.
Alright. So we've run the script. It was
successful. We jump back to our tutorial.
So now we're going to run Docker Slim,
and we're saying that we want to build
an image.
We have a target,
which is our base layer, I guess, and
then the tag, which is what our small
image is going to be called. Yes. I'm
not sure what the issue to be probe
is. We can come back to that, but
we do have a command to execute. So
I'm assuming
this is what is run for the intelligence
to kick in, understand the files that are
being used, and then spits out the small
image.
So let's kick that off.
And I'm curious. You wanna give me a
bit more information on the HTTP
probe?
Yeah. Of course. So
one thing that haven't been that hasn't been
specifically mentioned is this probing.
So while doing
the runtime analysis,
we have an idea that the target image
or the target container,
it should be probed.
And probing could be, like, done in different
ways.
Probably the more since most of the time,
we are trying to minimize our, like,
services,
like, web services images,
the problem would be calling the HTTP API,
and that's where the HTTP probe comes in.
But you can also try to minify a
an image for a CLI application,
like in this example, where we just take
the
base
image and try to minify it to keep
only the curl executable in it. So in
this case, we don't need HTTP probe, which
is enabled by default, so we are disabling
it. Otherwise, the will start complaining.
And instead, we use another probe, which is
an exec probe. And the exec probe means
run a certain,
well, executable
inside of the target container.
Okay.
I'm just Yeah. Skimming the output here.
One of the things to look for there
is,
in caps, it says minified. So it shows
you the size of the original image and
then the optimized image so you can see
what the reduction looks like straight away.
Wow. So we've taken a base CentOS image,
which is 231
megs,
and we've optimized that down to just 13
meg of an image. That's quite an improvement.
That's actually
much larger than I much more of a
compression than I expected, to be honest.
And remember, these are the that compression point
is in is is important.
We used to get asked quite a lot,
you know, are you just compressing the images?
These are not compressed images. So this is
just
a raw image versus a raw image.
Yeah. Maybe I just compressed there in the
slightly wrong context. I'm I'm not I'm not
criticizing.
It's just that, you know, sometimes people think
that all we do is compress images, and
that's absolutely not what we do at all.
Yeah. Okay.
So the things I think are interesting here,
obviously, the size
is dramatically smaller, which is nice. We have
some sort of report dot JSON. I'm not
sure what that is yet.
We have something called X-ray if we want
to learn more about the optimized image.
Now we could take into each of those,
but I think first, I should just
run the image and make sure it still
works.
Yeah. You can you could probably go with
the docker images first to
really see the difference
in size, I mean.
Yep. So here is my curl image, the
13 meg versus the latest,
which was two thirty one.
We can do a Docker container run r
m cuntos curl.
I can't remember. Does it modify any of
the metadata, like the entry point, the command,
the labels, the environments? Are are those all
persistent?
Is this
Yeah. The entry point is persistent. So the
shell is there,
which is not something you usually would do.
And the environment is persisted as well.
And we still can curl.
There we go.
That's pretty cool. I like this.
So
if we run
history on it,
what will we see?
The same metadata
and then just a blob ad for that.
Okay.
Okay. Let
damage works.
The history, I can see you've added the
30 meg blobs. There's a single layer.
We have a report, and we have an
X-ray command.
What's the report? What would I use that
for?
Well,
for the report, we can touch up on
it
later.
Essentially, it's the information about the Cisco made
and files
accessed and maybe some extra stuff, like what
was the architecture,
like what was the detected Linux distribution,
and what was, like, a language runtime environment.
It's not something you check usually. Like, it's
more for us.
But,
usually,
like,
alongside with this report, you may also find
other artifacts,
like like auto generated seccomp profile or FRR
profile.
So the concept of these artifacts,
like
monitoring artifacts or, like, intelligence artifacts being shipped
from inside of your target container back to
your host machine is an important one,
but report is probably not something you are
interested in at the moment.
X-ray is, like, a more
valuable thing to show.
X-ray is for analyzing images.
It's a
command of the.
And
you can actually use it for any image,
not just a slimmed image like anyone.
If you wanna investigate what's inside of a
well, your production image or of some public
image from Docker Hub or whatever,
you can just run Docker Slim X-ray,
the target image,
and we'll show you
some intelligence about it. Let's try it for
the image.
Yeah. I think we have a command here.
Yeah. So Yeah. It's pretty simple. X-ray target
and then export all data artifact.
Well, the second part is not mandatory, but
let's
keep it.
Okay. So
is this just a list of all the
files?
By layers and also with some extreme information
about the layers.
Yeah. It's kind of
important information if you wanna understand your images.
The problem with it is that it's not
really presented
well.
It's not really human readable as you can
clearly see.
And that's why there is this second flag.
Now since you used it,
it also saved
the same information
in the entire archive.
And we have a tool to actually visual
visualize these
X-ray reports.
So it's for, like, savvy, Docker steam users.
They can upload
this
tar archive to our SaaS portal,
and it will show
the same information but in a much,
like,
more need representation.
Okay.
So if you wanna see it, you could
SCP this archive to your
machine and just open the SaaS in the
browser
just to give an impression of the contents
of this image of, like, the layers and
to the
meta information.
Okay. So let me pull that down, and
then we've got a couple of questions in
the chat
that we'll tackle. So let me do s
v p. We're at
data
artifact. Okay. I can I
can feel the question from from Russell who
asks, so is X-ray
a bit like Dive?
Certainly,
the content of X-ray
exposes
the kind of information that you would need
to get that sort of
dive like experience.
But what we're about to show you now
is the Slim AI portal.
So you can upload this tar of the
artifacts,
and you will get a visual representation
of what just happened.
And in fact,
when we started at Slim, we started implementing
all of this doing the optimization in the
SaaS platform,
and
the overwhelming feedback was
what the heck just happened? What happened to
my container?
So, actually, we rolled all the way back,
and the first thing we properly implemented in
the SaaS platform
was really deep sort of introspection
and exploration
of container images
wherever they might be. So the SaaS platform
is a bit like Google for container images.
You you can connect to all of your
public and private registries. You can search them.
You can access your containers, and you can
do deep introspection
and security analysis of those container images.
And what we're about to see is just
a tiny bit of what you can actually
visualize with the container images by
using Docker Slim to upload, you know, these
artifacts into the into the visualization tool.
Alright.
And we have one more question
from who
is asking if Docker Slim works on the
m one Mac and if that's something that's
coming.
Yeah. I I have I have
something to share.
So
there is a known problem with it. So
it does work.
Like, there is nothing
unsupported currently for m ones.
But when you are on when you are
on an m one mug,
you actually can have two
different
modes of container execution.
If it's an R built,
then it will be like a native run,
But it could be an, like, a traditional
inter Intel
x
run
on an ARM processor.
So we will have to use emulation for
that. Like, what whatever Docker desktop on
Mac OS actually uses.
And in this case, the sensor has to
be all the same architectures,
of course.
But the traditional or, like, the default installation
method, it just pulls in two binaries, the
Docker Slim itself
for ARM and the sensor also for ARM.
So if you try to run a non
ARM
container
on an ARM
machine,
will
inject an ARM sensor into it. And, of
course, it will not work. But,
yeah, but you can be smart enough and
just download the right version of the sensor
from our GitHub and replace it on your
machine, and then it will inject the. It
will inject it, and everything will work.
So
it does work, but we have to fix
the installation procedure.
We have to be, like, smart and understand
the target architecture of the container and inject
the right sensor. And this is something
well, if someone wants to contribute, we will
just love this, but
it's open source.
But
this is on our list, definitely.
Awesome. Thank you for tackling that question. Hope
that helps. In fact in fact, to dive
into this particular sort of thorny issue,
we did a couple of livestreams recently where,
first of all, we created our own
derivative OS for the Raspberry Pi specifically. So
we created a a container
operate
a a a of Ubuntu derived operating system
specifically
designed
to run containers.
So that ran in just 98 91 megabytes
of of memory.
And then we created our own optimized base
images
to then build our apps on top of
as well. And then we were generating a
whole bunch of different applications
in containers using that, you know, because it's
ARM 64 and ARM 32,
and then uploading those into our
our platform and using Docker Slim to see
where all of the rough edges were to
sort of document where where the issues are,
where we where we need to improve.
K.
Alright. So we should probably, like, speed up
a bit if you wanna see some more
advanced use cases. Yeah.
Alright. We'll we'll tackle one more question very
quickly, and then we'll we'll get back to
the the terminal. So George Castro is at
the chat saying,
very big long comment. It's not gonna affect
my screen. But it would be neat to
see Slim containers on something like a large
Kubernetes cluster. I imagine there would be lots
of bandwidth saving implications,
especially
when you have a cluster with lots of
nodes.
Is that like, what are the main drivers
you see people adopting this kind of technology?
That is a use case for sure.
When we were at KubeCon,
there are a number of people stopping by
that were already using either Docker Slim or
Slim AI
specifically to address
either sort of, you know, savings in bandwidth
costs or in some cases,
just being able to deploy their containers in
the first place. When you look at AIML
containers,
they can be multi gigabyte containers.
They they sort of grow and grow. And
Docker Slim can really help, you know, get
those under control, get those into a manageable
size so that deployments aren't just quicker,
they're actually reliable.
And also, you know, when you're pushing them
around
multi cloud environments, for example, can really save
some sort of transit costs.
Alright. Awesome. Thank you.
Alright. Let's get back to the terminal so
we can get through some more of these
demos. So we've taken a look at Slimming
down an image.
Demo two is something called advanced HTTP
probing,
where it's a more real scenario to modify
the image of a Node. Js server with
a nontrivial HTTP API.
Yeah. Quick question. I I will look into
the contents of the minified image first or
not,
which is fine also. We can just skip
it because I think everyone already understood that
that is, like, a one single layer image.
Yeah.
Yeah. We can do that if you want,
or we can move on to the next
demo. Which which you think is more fun?
I mean, real quick. Let's I think because
there was a question about Dive.
Yeah. Yeah. So do you want me to
export it and then open it, or is
this what the artifacts are?
Let's upload it to the It's take that
artifact to the portal. Of course. Yeah. Sorry.
Alright.
Let's go to the Slim AI portal.
So what am I doing here? I haven't
done this before.
Yeah. Just you see this
X-ray mentioning under under the search box.
Mhmm.
It's exact specifically for
Docker Slim users.
Alright.
So
where did I download that to? That's the
question. There we go.
Okay.
Oh, shiny.
So Russell was asking about Dive. This is,
you know, a visualization
of, you know, what the container now looks
like.
Okay. So
you can see essentially clicks through the stuff
or click on the filter, and it will
show you some, like, brief information about the
number of binary files or a number of
the
other type of files. Yeah.
Yeah.
Remember, it was a center as distro,
and we tried to extract just curl out
of it. So if you go to the
filter and filter it by
binary files, you will see actually how many
dependencies
a curl binary has.
Yep. There's all the dynamically linked files there.
Yep. Yep.
And if you look at the overview
on the on the left there.
So this is quite useful.
You know, one of the things what you
can do on the platform when you're actually
using this platform directly is you can have
a look at your containers in your registry
and your Slim containers in your registry, and
you can compare them side by side.
So if you want to see exactly what
happened as a result of optimizing your container,
You can see a side by side view
of this is what was removed.
This
is the security profile as a result of
the the minification process.
For example, there are no shells in this
container, and you see there files with special
permissions. If you were to look at the
CentOS
base image, you would find, like any Linux
distro, there's a bunch of files with set
UID and set GID,
you know, stickies on various binaries, and those
are gone. So you at a glance, you
can see sort of the changes that are
made here. There was a shell in this
image. Yeah. Because it was an entry point.
So it's it's not like you execute curl.
You do it through, like, a Sage
run curl.
Yeah. Because I when we filter this by
the binaries,
there was user Ben Bash
here.
Yeah.
It's not expected behavior because
that's what's part of the entry point, which
also could be changed if you are, like,
careful enough. You can use the array version
of the entry point, and then the shell
is not mandatory.
Got it.
Cool. Very nice tone. Good for seeing what
we have. I love the filters as well.
I've been able to break that down to
binaries and text. Very The idea the idea
here is to provide the same kind of
user experience
for your minimized images
and for any other image.
I don't really wanna feature the portal here.
But if you can go if you go
to the search, don't do it now. If
you go to the search, you can actually
search images, like, from any other public registry
and then see exactly the same in the
exactly the same UI
on the same kind of information.
Yeah. Let's get back to the more real
demo.
Okay. So step two is we're gonna take
a Node. Js a Node. Js HTTP API,
and we're gonna slim that down.
So I'm just gonna clone your Docker Slim
examples here. Yeah. So the thing is that
the previous demo,
it wasn't really well, it was rather artificial.
Like,
I I don't think there are many people
out there taking,
like,
vanilla Linux distro and trying to make it,
like, I don't know, one tool image
out of it.
But this is much more real example. So
this image
is
just a typical Node. Js
web service
with a nontrivial HTTP API surface. So it
has, like, a bunch of methods.
The thing is that
we would like to
make to
probe it
not
trivially
by just calling, like, you know, the slash
endpoint,
but instead to go over all the exposed
API endpoints.
And we don't want to do this manually.
Like,
I'm not in, like, in in the mood
to actually list all the endpoints.
So instead,
Docker Slim has
one of its built in capabilities.
It understands
API specs. Like, if you go with an
open API with the spec
and point to
it,
it will actually understand all the available endpoints,
and they'll try to probe them one by
one. So let's try to run this example.
Of course, first, we need to make to
build the fat version of the image.
Then it just ran make,
but make is not a part of of
Docker Slim in any way. You can see
that, actually, this make resulted in a very
simple Docker build command.
Okay.
So we're currently doing this.
And then you want me to do a
run and a curl?
Oh, yeah. Just do them one one by
one one by one because the like, what
what you're actually doing now, you are
running one of our examples. So Docker Slim
in a separate repository.
It has a, like, tens of examples how
to minify
different images and how to,
like, go from these trivial scenario to more
advanced one.
So
but all of these or most of these
examples, they follow the same pattern. Just build
the fat version of the image,
run, see that it works,
go build the Slim version, and run it
and see that it works. So we are
just trying to follow it. Okay. So we've
run all those commands. We can see the
build has built a one gig image from
this application.
And we ran it. I curled it, passed
it through j q. Things are good. I
shut it back down.
So the fun part is gonna be the
make Slim build. Right?
Right.
And if I just take a look at
what Oh, no. Please don't. No.
Just run it and see the command. Yeah.
Well, okay. And just try to find the
very first command, yeah, after the after the
make
call.
Yeah. So Docker Slim build, HTTP probe, and
we point it to the spec YAML, which
must have been as where the open API
spec is.
We tell it to crawl,
and
then we tell it the image that we
want to crawl again.
And in the in in the chat that
we share, I've
shared a link to an article that I
wrote that explains
how to use
probes and includes
and what, you know, what they're used for
and how to use them to achieve, you
know, different results.
So if you want to share that in
the chat, then there's a a reference there
that people can dig into to sort of
look at how these things
can be utilized.
Okay. I
will put this in the show notes for
people to read as well. There. Lots there.
Thank you.
Okay. So we did get a question in
the chat, but I think, like, Paul just
handled it.
Russell was asking,
so if your archive uploads to the portal
private to the uploader, I e, if I
had a private container, can I still use
the Slim portal to analyze it, or would
it make my image public?
Well, we don't make anything public. It's
just the metadata
to describe
the container that has been produced through the
Slimming process,
not the container itself.
Yeah. That I think that's really important. We
did not upload a container image to the
portal. We uploaded metadata about the container image
to the portal. Right. But it also will
stay available only for you.
Yeah.
Now
that said,
if you want to use the portal and
you have private registries,
you can connect to private registries
and do those comparisons on the portal using,
you know, authenticated
sessions for either individuals or teams within your
organization.
But what we've just shown you, it didn't
expose anything private
to the world.
Alright.
Okay. Let's talk about less compression then. So
we went from a one gig
image,
and this is telling us that we spout
out something that is 91
meg.
Again
okay. Just over 91 meg. That is a
huge
difference.
I mean, that's massive.
Yeah. That's a 10 times reduction right there.
Yeah. Very, very cool. I like that. Yeah.
We could probably achieve, like, a comparable result
if we just go and carefully
craft this
production version of this image,
like, using, I don't know, distroless
Yeah. You know, like, this node. Js distroless
from Google
and, like, carefully copying
all the needed packages and, like, doing the
staged
Docker build,
whatever,
will would be pretty much the same in
the end,
like, on the same order.
But
it would take us,
like, a lot of time to actually learn
this,
how to do this, and also then to
to prepare
the,
like, accurate
version of the image. And with Docker Slim,
you just actually saw it took us, like,
I don't know, less than a minute to
produce the end result.
And that that speaks to the origins of
Docker Slim. You know? Keep your existing workflows
and add
this process on the end that does the
optimization
for you. If you're using something like Distroless,
then now it's you need to,
learn the process of doing multistage builds, for
example. If you're using Alpine,
you need to learn the process of the
sort of additive packages.
I'm starting with something very small, and now
I'm a distro maintainer because I need to
know what are the packages that I require
application requires
in order to build up from almost nothing
to something that supports my application.
Whereas what we're doing is tipping things on
their head.
Start with something large that fully supports your
application that you're probably familiar with or your
teams are familiar with. In this case,
I think this is an Ubuntu based container,
and I know you're using Ubuntu in the
on this server here,
and reduce that down.
Now
I've been recently experimenting
with things like Alpine and Distroless
and and also
containers that do conform to best practice that
are built on top of, you know, Debian
and sent well, not sent to us these
days, but, you know, Alma and
Ubuntu.
And seeing, well, if I take an Alpine
and a distroless container, can I still optimize
those with Docker Slim? And the answer is,
well, yes, you can.
And in the examples that I've been working
with,
I end up with container images that have
gone through the the reductive process.
Starting with Ubuntu, for example,
I get something that is 25 megabytes. This
was a simple Python application that implemented a
RESTful API. And I put the same app
inside
an Alpine base image and a distroless base
image.
And within one or two megabytes,
the optimized containers were the same size.
So you can optimize
Alpine and Distroless as well even if you've
well prepared those Alpine and Distroless containers
because there will be things inside them that
your application doesn't require. I did this last
week with the team at Influx looking at
some of their containers,
which are
statically compiled go binaries inside container images,
some of which are using Debian based images,
some of which are using Alpine based images.
And even on the Alpine base images, we
were looking at a 20 megabyte
reduction
on the optimized container going through Docker Slim.
And on the Debian side of things, it's
a bit like what we're looking at here.
It was, you know, hundreds of megabytes smaller.
Nice.
This seems like one of those things that's
just
almost a no a no brainer. Like, I
I meet a lot of people that are
adopting containers and Kubernetes,
and, you know, they don't know how to
make their images smaller and optimize them. Really,
they just wanna get shit done. They just
wanna build an image and deploy their application
and not worry about this. They're not container
experts. They've not been doing this for six
years. Sometimes they've been doing it for six
weeks. And they've been able to say, hey.
Just use this Doppler slim thing in your
CI pipeline and then, you know, push through
your image to a registry and then jump
that. Like,
I I I've struggled to see why more
people just would use this by default.
Let let's let's be careful here. So
so and, you know, like, every magic, it
comes at a price.
So,
like, first of all, I
have to be, like,
fair and and just say it out loud
that I used to be skeptical about Docker
Slim s two,
not because of its value, like, not because
of the like, it's the value is huge.
Like, if I can reduce, like, a one
gig to 50 megabytes in no time, well,
the value is huge for me. But I
was skeptical about the quality of the results
because,
well, I just don't believe a tool that
removes
90% of my image and claims the end
result, like, workable.
Well, no way.
But
after learning how much
of the intelligence is actually there is inside
and and through how many different use cases
we already
over this past seven year been through,
the success rate
of the produced
Slim images,
like, to be functional
is actually
extremely high. I wouldn't expect this to be
that high, But the number of stories we
have on GitHub,
the number of users we have in my
our, like,
cumulative
community,
and the number of reported
success stories,
well, I still don't like, cannot believe in
it, but it's it's,
well, it works.
But
even
with all this pretty high success rate,
I would not advise
anyone to put a Slim image in production
without putting it through as thorough testing first.
Right. Like, probably,
the the
very first step,
and this is another motor of our, like,
company,
is you need to understand what's inside of
your images. So not just slim them down,
but also understand what's inside.
So
whatever your preferred way, that way, dive or
Docker Slim X-ray
and then upload it to the portal or
some like, I don't know, Docker Docker extract
command. Whatever. Just go and see what's inside.
Because you, as an application developer, probably know
that, okay. I have this or I the
this static assets folder. It should have been
there, but it's not there. So probably the
optimization wasn't smart enough.
Well, you have to kind of be careful
about the produced results.
And if you detected something like that, Docker
Slimming has, like, just tremendous amount of of
knobs to actually
configure these extra
included
files or some excluded files or, like, changed
permissions, whatever. Like, it has a lot of
knobs. So you see, by default, the build
command, it just accepts, like, two parameters,
but you can go up to, like, a
hundred to fine tune the end result.
That's one thing. And another one,
go like, push this image through testing phase.
Like, if Docker Slim is a part of
your CICD pipeline,
it cannot be the last one before actually
shipping the image. It should be, like, the
penultimate
one
before
pushing this image to acceptance testing.
And then once it's tested,
then you can go to production.
That's,
like, an important
kind of, I don't know, point to to
focus on.
Awesome.
I mean, those points are also just good
container hygiene as well, though. Like, people should
be testing their images regardless of the tooling
that they're using before it goes to prod.
So it's good that you're kinda doubling down
on that and just saying, like, you know,
seriously,
run tests against this container image because you
just never know.
And testing, it doesn't literally mean that you
have to write tests and execute them. Testing
could be done in production.
Well, like, I've been
doing it myself, like, in different setups.
If you can limit the amount of traffic
that you send to this
new version of the image, like, do the
standard canary thing, you can minimize the image.
You can deploy it and just either mirror
traffic to it or shed some minimal amount
of of traffic to it and see,
like, your metrics if you don't have enough
test coverage, which is also fine.
Yeah.
A good project for that is the captain
project from the CNCF,
which does auto remediation based on header header
rates.
Yeah, that would be a good a good
partner there.
Okay. We we we've been talking a lot.
So let's get back to our demos here.
Let's take some commands.
Yeah.
So We could we could probably skip so
let let's decide. We have two more.
We probably don't have time for both.
Like, one is
auto generated second profiles.
Since
Docker Slim actually
part of its intelligence is the graph of
system calls,
we can just leverage this data to produce
a second profile to auto generate a second
profile
that would be a good starting point. I
would not say it's the,
like,
second profile you would put into production,
but it's a good starting point. And you
can just fine fine tune it further and
then ship it.
That's one example we can see.
Or we have something
rather secret that
hasn't been announced yet.
It's Kubernetes support for
Docker Slim.
Despite the name, Docker Slim,
we understand
that there are different run times at the
moment to run containers,
and probably the most popular one is Kubernetes.
So we are starting adding more run times,
and Kubernetes is the first one. So which
one?
Well, I mean, you saw that Kubernetes one
pretty well, so I feel that we're gonna
have to do that. Right?
Plus, it sounds like the riskiest one. So,
you know, I do love a challenge.
I mean, especially when I'm not doing the
typing.
Okay. Let's let's go for Kubernetes then.
Alright.
Shall I share my screen? Yeah. Let's do
it.
Window.
Yeah.
Works.
It does? I'm just popping it up now.
Alright. You're on the oh, can you
hold on. Your window's a
different size.
Yeah. Can you I think your terminal's a
bit tall. Can you
Yeah. It's better now.
I can see I can see the
I don't know if I can see the
the bottom, though.
That's fine because I'm not at the bottom.
Ah, okay. Yeah. Perfect. Yeah. Thank you. Yeah.
So before we we jump to to the
to typing,
as I just mentioned, like,
Duckers Slim,
it does runtime analysis of images to minify
them.
Like, in 2021,
I think there is very few people who
actually run their production images,
like, in standalone mode.
Most likely, your service has, like, I don't
know, a bunch of sidecars
and,
like, several external API dependencies and maybe a
database.
Like, it's gonna be hard to
optimize,
like, to slim down such an image that
actually requires
five different other endpoints to be available.
So the first thing we implemented for Docker
Slim was Docker Compose mode support
because this is much more realistic scenario when
you have your image
surrounded by all your dependencies.
So
one of the things Docker Slim can do
now is actually take
instead of target image, take the whole
Docker Docker Compose file, like the YAML file
you you, like, normally write,
And then you just tell it what image
out of the all images mentioned there are
to optimize,
and it will start much like Docker Compose
up
the whole
scenario
and just go and do the probing for
the target image out of these
images specified in this YARL file.
But I wanted to show something slightly different.
Pretty much the same thing could be done
for Kubernetes.
So what we can do,
we can try injecting
the sensor,
this tiny little sensor of Docker Slim
a workload that actually runs as a Kubernetes
deployment or as a Kubernetes
replica set or, like, daemon set, whatever you
you want,
and
start probing it using
well, whatever.
And once we have all this intelligence
in an artifact file generated,
we just should ship it back from the
cluster
to your main driver app, which is like
the CLI itself.
And then the rest is exactly the same
as for any other scenario here, as for
the stand alone mode, for instance. So we
will produce
a slim version
for
a workload that actually runs on Kubernetes.
But once we get into the Kubernetes world,
like, the
possibilities become just endless.
Because in Kubernetes,
we can
start doing, like, traffic shifting
right in your cluster. Why not? Like, you
you you if you have a deployment of
10 different port of 10 ports,
you can actually try slimming it down right
in production. Just start up
the eleventh port,
send some traffic to it,
optimize it, and slim it down.
So let's see how it works.
What I did here while we were talking,
I cloned our
main repository
and
built
from
the main branch because it's
something that hasn't been released yet, but it
already
it's already been merged.
So, like, nothing fancy here. Just go build.
So now we have the
Yeah. I think it's in the dist.
And this is not on our machine. Right?
No. No. No. This is that Intel machine.
Okay. So now let's let's do
a nasty thing.
Let's
move this
this binaries to the
to place where they will be reachable.
I think it's a fresh one.
So
if we now get back to these examples
folder,
there is a new example
mentioning Kubernetes deployment optimization.
So
first, we have to create a
cluster,
and we have
a kind already preinstalled on this machine, so
this should be
done
in no time.
But the cluster is not really a requirement.
So you can use, like, any cluster. Remote
one is also fine as long as you
can run images on it and to to,
like, keep still CP like things.
So
when the cluster will be up,
we will just deploy
an application
which consists of two
of two components.
The one is a deployment. It's like a
regular
Node. Js service
that runs as a Kubernetes deployment.
And another one is
a Redis
deployment.
So we assume that this
Node. Js application to run, it needs to
call Redis
well, to store some data or, I don't
know, retrieve some data. It doesn't doesn't really
matter.
The idea is that you won't wouldn't be
able to
do a runtime analysis of such an application
without having a radius running around.
So let's review the
application itself.
So we have,
like, a server,
which is, like, trivial.
It's
a API
for the server part, and it has Redis
package installed, and it creates a client.
And then
upon a get request,
it goes and calls Redis and reports success.
That's pretty much it.
So
it's
packaged
as a Kubernetes
deployment.
Like, nothing fancy here. Just a
simplistic deployment
that exposes
a port.
Like, this place called, there are such as
to make these examples reusable, but, essentially, you
can just put app names there, like, literally.
And the well, it's fronted by a service.
Again, create standard.
And
a very similar thing for Redis.
Again,
trivial deployment
running a vanilla server Redis image,
and it's exposed
via service.
So
we can
make
build the fat version of the image. And,
again,
this
I hear you,
I I know you hate the way the
make files are made because they are full
of includes,
but in the end, they generate super simple
commands.
So, like, you see, it was just a
regular Docker build. Yep.
And now we can
run it.
And oops. No. Before running, we have to
somehow deliver this image to the Kubernetes cluster.
Otherwise, it will not be able to
Oh, we don't have kubectl.
Yeah. I'm grabbing it now.
Yeah. I've I've used many kubectl
for
everything,
and I never thought.
Alright. Download.
While we are waiting,
just notice how long it takes to actually
inject this local image
to a local
Kubernetes cluster
just simply because of its size. Like, these
fat images, they are insane.
Yeah. I thought you were gonna hit the
test there and say, look how long it
takes them to copy and paste some commands,
but I'm glad you didn't. Alright.
You should have kept control now. Sorry about
that.
And we are still copying the image.
How big? Yeah. We're done.
Oh, yeah. If you if you're on
and just see what's
what's in there,
like,
we all know how Kubernetes deployment looks like.
Right?
Just a regular
app deployment,
a
regular radius deployment,
like,
should
be working.
Yeah. We're trying to
do some port forwarding
and calling it
with curl.
And as a result, we get, like, a
response. So okay. The fit version works.
So let's try to minimize
this
image that actually runs right now in a
Kubernetes cluster.
So
we have a command,
a make target, actually,
and it says,
make me a slim version of the image
from the running version.
So if you run it,
you'll see what what's actually happening here. A
familiar already familiar
Docker Slim build command,
but the target this time is not an
image. Is not the local one. Like, remember,
during the very first demo, you pulled
the center's
image first to your machine.
But in this case, we're not pulling anything.
We are just targeting
a workload,
which could be, like, a deployment or a
daemon set or a replica set and
maybe even Cruncher. I don't remember.
That that runs
in Kubernetes.
And we just say what tech to use
the Slim version of the image.
Like, we have this beautiful
colorful output as as always.
There was some probing
in the middle, so it also
port
did like, Docker Slim driver app, it also
did some port forwarding
and probed. In this case, the probing was
the standard one, which is
quite simplistic. It's just a plain HTTP get
request to the slash endpoint,
but it was done.
And then
the
paged
port actually was
killed,
and we and we got a minified version
of the image. And it says it's 93
megabytes.
So we can now
do
docker images.
We should see that the
original version of the image was also around
one gigabyte one gigabyte. Yeah. Right.
And the minified version is 10 times smaller,
and it was done inside of a Kubernetes
cluster.
So if you now
stop
the fed version
and instead
load the
Slim version into the cluster, it should be
much faster.
And try to run it.
I hope it will work.
So,
again, to run it, we just apply these
manifests.
So what do we have here?
The fat one is still being terminated,
and we have something for the Slim one.
So if we if we just look at
this port, we should see probably we
should see probably
the Slim version of the image
in use.
So,
yep,
it's a slim one.
Nice. But does but does it work?
That's, I guess.
Yes. It does.
Magic.
Very cool.
Yep. This is not something that
has been released,
but it's already in in master. So it
gives me some hope.
Very cool. I like that a lot.
So
what's the the plan around the Kubernetes
support? Is there, like, a broader mission that
you have as Slim AI to bring more
automation with that inside of the cluster? Like,
what I'm trying to understand in my head
right now is, like, should I adopt Docker
Slim at a CICD layer and build images
and push the registry?
Or is there gonna be, like, a secret
sauce and cluster
thing
happening
at some point? Like, how do you see
these two different paths for Slimmington images differing?
I don't Martin, do you have something to
share?
Yeah. So I think there's room for both.
You know, the the original
process of
running something through CICD and producing a unified
image that you run through validation and acceptance
testing,
that's all well and good. But one of
the use cases that was presented to us
talking to people at KubeCon
earlier in the year
was they wanted to deploy the fat containers
into their clusters.
They wanted to have Slim containers automatically generated.
They wanted to roll those Slim containers into
the service requests automatically,
then use observability
to determine if they were successfully handling
the load or not. If they were not,
they wanted to fall back to the original
containers
and then report back the status of those
observability
reports in order to inform what needed to
be changed or improved about the minification process
that those minified containers,
the next time they they get automatically generated
in the cluster,
succeed
with what they needed to do. So
I think that was a very
Kubernetes
take on, like, how to do, you know,
the minification. I've got this massive cluster of
computers,
and computers can automate
away a lot of this for me and
just tell me
where stuff is broken, if things are broken
indeed,
and how to how to remedy that. So
I I think there's there's there's a place
for both,
and I think the Kubernetes solution is very
much talking to those people that just love
to use clusters to solve problems at scale.
Yeah. I think another
cool effect from doing it within the cluster.
You know, I think I I my my
own personal way here would be to Slim
and CICD push to production, but I still
think bringing Docker Slim into the cluster is
good from
the seccomp part of it as well.
They've been able to do a continuous profiling
of those test calls in my application and
update the seccomp profiles in real time could
be a shit. Those security challenges there because
what's a real request versus what's a fake
request? I don't know.
But, yeah, there's definitely some interesting stuff here,
I think, for for playing around with it.
So yeah. Yeah. Like, you know, like, not
not everyone is on Kubernetes,
and not everyone should be on Kubernetes.
Yeah.
Sorry. I'm sorry. I don't use Kubernetes. I
don't run my blog on Kubernetes.
I know I should be, but no. Sorry.
Yeah. But so we have to support people
who is not on Kubernetes
yet or who want to be ever. So
we have to target, like, all the other
scenarios.
But for people who is on Kubernetes,
they are probably
like, they probably know what they are doing.
So for them, we could provide, like, a
much more
sophisticated solution. Like, it could be an operator.
It's not something that we, like, really have
on on the road map. I'm just, like,
thinking out loud as an engineer and as
someone who actually have been operating
Kubernetes services.
Like, we could ship an operator
that would be doing this image optimization,
leveraging Docker Slim under the hood
right in your cluster. So So you could,
I don't know, annotate your services, like your
deployment that you would like to see
slimmed down. And the separator would be watching
from all the new deployments having this annotation.
And then do this optimization
right on production cluster by spinning up, like,
one extra port for every deployment and sharing
some traffic to it, removing it if it
produces,
like, too much noise and, like, stuff like
that, and then generating an image for you,
pushing it to your registry,
and triggering another CI pipeline
to actually ship a Canary deployment of this
slim version of the service and see if
it's not noisy. Like, if it's not too
noisy, maybe just continue to the full on
rollout. So,
like, as I already mentioned, like, possibilities are
endless once you get into this Kubernetes world
because,
like, you all can automate everything.
And that's just why I love Kubernetes,
like, because of its API and automation
capabilities.
You've started the Kubernetes trolling now in the
comments. So
I
love the group that's going on with case
at the moment.
Yeah. I've been using Kubernetes a long time,
and I still have no idea what the
fuck I'm doing either. So there was a
in line with what Ivan was saying, a
big pod left a comment as well to
saying that, actually,
the complicated images where the probing could be
tough, bringing us into the cluster and doing
it over a certain period of time with
real user traffic. That's a really good avenue
as well. And another one I thought of
as you were kind of talking is, like,
third party images as well. Like, you know,
I I don't really build NGINX even though
I know I can make it smaller. I
don't really build Redis and Kafka
or all these other post queries, MariaDB's, etcetera.
Because the images are built and they're official.
And, yeah, they could be smaller. So I
wonder if bringing for third party images that
may cluster, bringing Docker Slim into the cluster
actually is quite an interesting way to do
it as well. And because I don't I
don't have a build pipeline for them, and
I don't want one for them either.
If I had
that demo well, in fact, you you did
it, which was the the curl example at
the very beginning. We have another example which
uses the NGINX official image, which does exactly
the same thing for NGINX.
So if you're using NGINX in production as
a reverse proxy,
you can automatically generate, you know, a much
smaller image that's in there much faster to
deploy and push around your infrastructure.
Yeah. That's that's And the the reduction in
size was similar. It was a 10 x
reduction.
Yeah. I think all the reductions we've done
today seem to have been around 10 x.
That's your magic number, and it's a good
one to have as well for for me
to starting point. Ten ten to 30 times
is usually what we see depending on the
sort of
application language framework.
Awesome.
Alright. Well, I mean, I'm happy for people
to keep trolling Kubernetes in the comments section,
but I think we should probably
see
any last words, any last questions. If you
wanna get them in now, audience, now is
your last chance to get questions for Martin
and Ivan.
Do either of you have anything else you
wanna share before we finish up for today?
No. Other than to encourage people to if
they if they like what they've seen and
and that and they see some benefit for
using it in their own environments, give it
a try. Docker Slim is fully open source.
It's available on GitHub. Just come and grab
it and test it. Have a play with
it. We're always interested to hear new and
interesting
and unusual use cases. So if you find
an edge case, tell us about that as
well. So hey, Nuno. It's good to see
you.
So, yeah, try Docker Slim. And, also, the
Slim SaaS platform is also free to use
as well,
which can do all of the things that
we've just demonstrated to you in a web
platform and connect all of your public and
private registries. So give a try. And if
if you have success there, then maybe take
a look at the SlimSaaS platform as well
and see what additional insight you can get
about your container images, including
security analysis, for example.
Alright.
And, of course, like, if you have any
further questions, like, just join join our Discord.
Like, we are always happy to to chat
about this. Even if it's not a question,
just just you feel like talking about containers,
join our Discord.
Alright. Awesome. Well, thank you so much for
for joining me both of you. It's been
an absolute pleasure learning more about Docker Slim.
All of the demos work as well, except
for the stuff that I broke by not
having control available, but, you know, we got
past that. And so, hopefully, we'll speak again
soon. Have a a great day. And to
everyone watching, thank you. We'll see you next
time.
Thank you very much.